[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about all the major and
minor clans and races in the world of
the seven deadly sins thank you guys
again for all the support you've shown
for the previous two seven deadly sins
video every sin explained and all the
Ten Commandments explained while doing
research for those two videos I noticed
how interesting all of the different
races and clans of rehtaeh were along
with all of their unique powers and
abilities and of course all of them in
their own way played an important role
in the history of Britannia and so the
purpose of this video will be to give
you some insight about the fascinating
world and the world history of the land
in which the seven deadly sins takes
place if you enjoy the seven deadly sins
content on this channel be sure to leave
a like to let me know and if you are new
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell since we've gotten so
much support for the seven deadly sins
content here on the channel
lots more seven deadly sins content is
indeed on the way and Thomas from udon
TV said that these types of videos got
him interested in the story of the seven
deadly sins and now he is going to check
it out and by the way mood on TV is
seriously an amazing anime content
creator definitely check him out link in
the description however I want to make
sure that I'm keeping the videos fresh
and diverse for you guys so I created a
poll on Twitter to see what type of
seven deadly sins videos you most want
to see here on the channel in the future
be sure to follow the link in the
description to our Twitter or just
follow us at anime uproar and if you
prefer using Instagram we are posting
daily there as well so feel free to
check us out at anime uproar with that
said I will have to include spoilers
about the history and unique powers of
the different races and clans but I will
do my best not to spoil what actually
happens in the story from this point on
nonetheless if you are one of those
people who doesn't want any type of
spoiler what
however you have been warned by the way
let me know down in the comments which
clan or race you would most want to be a
member of if you had the choice and
without further ado let's start things
off with the five major races of
Britannia first we have the human race
this is the race that probably no one
will pick as their favourite since we're
all human anyways so that's kind of
boring but the humans are the largest
and number out of all the races and
clans and they currently control most of
the territory of Britannia humans are
known for having the shortest lifespans
and they are arguably the weakest out of
all the clans for example unlike the
members of other clans humans in general
are not usually born with magical powers
and they tend to have very fragile
mortal bodies and yet humans currently
control most of the land in Britannia
because the other clans were drastically
weakened during the holy war 3,000 years
earlier as a result of the war the demon
clan was sealed away and other clans
such as the giant Fairy and goddess
clans
suffered major losses and never fully
recovered as a result the nonhuman clans
and races tend to live in small secluded
areas such as the fairies who live in
the fairy kings forest and because of
this humans are free to rule over the
rest of Britannia largely unimpeded at
least at the beginning of the story
although most humans are weak compared
to members of the other clans there are
exceptions to this the holy Knights are
humans who trained and develop their
abilities including the ability to use
some forms of magic to such an extent
that they now possess powers far above
those of any average human and it is
said that one holy night can defeat an
entire army on his or her own however if
we look at the actual power levels of
most holy nights it is more accurate to
say that a holy night is stronger than a
few dozen ordinary men but not an entire
army other exceptions include humans
like esken or hooby
and manifesting an incredible power at
some point during his youth and he is
now considered one of the most powerful
characters in the entire series despite
being a human
there are also characters like bond who
was human at one point but became
immortal after drinking from the
Fountain of Youth
because humans are defined by their
mortality frailty and short lifespan
after he became immortal bond
technically stopped being a human in the
traditional sense then we have the giant
clan most members of the giant clan look
nearly identical to humans but they are
much larger in size and they have a lot
more power they are believed to be the
oldest clan to have inhabited the land
of Ratana and they are known for their
incredible physical strength and strict
warrior mentality the giant clan places
great value on fighting and the warrior
way of life and the leader of the giant
clan is chosen based on which of the
Warriors is the strongest and can defeat
the rest in battle in the holy war that
took place three thousand years ago the
giant clan fought alongside the goddess
Fairy and human clans against the demons
however an important figure in the
history of the Giants drôle is actually
a member of the ten commandments and was
sealed away alongside the other demons
inside the coffin of eternal darkness
drôle is a legendary giant who is
credited with inventing the sacred dance
of the Giants but after being defeated
in battle by széll drous the leader of
the ten commandments drol decided to
join the ten commandments and he became
the commandant of patience despite being
a giant drol differs from the average
giant in appearance because his skin is
blue and he has four arms instead of two
nevertheless he is believed to be the
strongest giant that we have come across
so far in the story on top of suffering
losses during the last holy war because
they are famous for being such fierce
warriors giants have often been hired as
mercenaries and they have been sent to
fight in various wars between human
kingdoms through
history this has led to the giant clan
losing a lot of its members so that now
there are only a few members of the
giant clan left alive Giants live much
longer than humans and they also have a
special ability called creation which
allows them to control and manipulate
the earth much like the earth benders
from Avatar The Last Airbender Giants
can use the earth to form great and
powerful weapons that they can then use
against their enemies the most well
known member of the giant to us is of
course Dian one of the members of the
seven deadly sins
but along with Diane and role of the ten
commandments we will also meet more
giants as the story goes on moving on to
the fairy clan like the giant clan the
fairy clan fought against the demon clan
during the holy war and also like the
Giants one of the fairy clans strongest
and most important members became one of
the ten commandments in the case of the
fairies gloxinia the first fairy king
joined the ten commandments as a result
gloxinia was sealed inside the coffin of
eternal darkness along with the other
demons over 3,000 years ago in general
members of the fairy race have a
childlike appearance pointy ears and
wings although some fairies do not grow
wings until much later in life and this
includes both King and Elaine who are
considered late bloomers as far as wings
are concerned fairies are closely
connected to nature and with the power
of the sacred tree fairies have the
ability to control nature as King does
when he uses his spirit spear chasta
fall the fairies lived peacefully inside
the fairy Kings forest for thousands of
years and at one point King the grizzly
sin of sloth served as the fairy king
and ruler of the forest until he left
the forest in search for his best friend
hell bro and when he did this he handed
off the duty to protect the forest to
his sister Elaine twenty years before
the beginning of the story bond had
entered the fairy Kings forest in search
of the Fountain of Youth
there he met and fell in love with
Elaine however the forest was suddenly
attacked and destroyed by a red demon
bond managed to survive because Elaine
made him drink from the Fountain of
Youth and turned him into an immortal
but Elaine herself was killed and the
forest was destroyed before she died
Elaine gave bond a seed that he could
use to restore the forest and some years
later he did just that
he created a new fairy Kings forest
where the fairies gather and where they
consider bond to be the true fairy king
since he restored a forest wall king who
should have been the rightful king
abandoned it however the true fairy king
must be chosen directly by the sacred
tree rather than by the fairies
themselves in terms of abilities fairies
can fly or levitate and they live much
longer than humans between a thousand
and fifteen hundred years fairies never
get sick they don't need a lot of sleep
and their bodies do not decompose even
after death fairies have the ability to
transform their bodies to look like
humans as we've seen both King and help
him do in the human world fairy wings
are thought to have magical healing
properties and for this reason the wings
of a fairy can fetch a high price as a
result fairies have sometimes been
killed by humans for their wings
apparently each fairy smells like a
specific flower or herb so for example
Elaine smells like lavender and King
smells like gold
osmanthus and now let's talk about the
demon clan in the holy war from 3,000
years ago the powerful demon clan faced
off against all of the other clans
combined including of course the humans
the fairies the Giants and the goddess
clan the demon clan was ultimately
defeated and almost completely sealed
away inside the coffin of eternal
darkness with some notable exceptions a
red demon who somehow managed to avoid
being sealed away ended up destroying
the fairy Kings forest and fraud Rijn
the selflessness of the ten commandments
had been sealed away separately but man
to escape when his seal was broken by
some humans he then went on to possess
the body of the great holy night Dreyfus
framed the seven deadly sins for the
murder of Zara trois and ultimately he
succeeded in releasing the other nine
members of the ten commandments from the
coffin of eternal darkness and of course
we can't forget Mele Yoda's who is also
a member of the demon clan but he was
not sealed away along with the other
demons the ruler of the demon clan is
the demon king and the demons are said
to come from a place known as the demon
realm although we know almost nothing
about the demon realm itself the demon
king is the most powerful demon and the
father of meliodas as well as esta rosa
and zell drous of the ten commandments
and one point the demon king took half
of his power and split it up into ten
pieces that gave each piece to one elite
demon warrior in the form of a
commandment this is how the Ten
Commandments were created and they serve
as a sort of demon clan special forces
who are especially trained and equipped
to destroy the enemies of the demons it
is interesting to note that even an
incredibly powerful demon warrior who is
a member of the ten commandments
possesses only about a tenth of the
demon Kings current power may Liotta's
himself was once the leader of the ten
commandments before turning his back on
them and betraying the demon clan there
are many different types of demons
including the red demons gray demons
green demons and so on however other
demons like Mele Oda's and most of the
members of the ten commandments don't
fit into these general categories and
they are very human-like in appearance
although they of course possess demonic
markings on their bodies and special
demon powers as bond learned the hard
way inside the fairy Kings forest demons
have more than one heart and removing
one of their hearts will not kill them
some demons have up to seven hearts but
they can be killed if all of their
hearts are destroyed members of the
demon clan are extremely powerful in
general and they are known to look down
on the other
races in fact demons see humans as
especially weak and pitiful and they are
known to feed on the souls of humans in
order to replenish their magical powers
a demons power is believed to be even
greater at night than it is during the
day powerful demons like members of the
ten commandments can control lesser
demons and many demons possess a number
of unique abilities including demonic
darkness the power of flight the power
to generate deadly dark flames called
purgatory fire that can injure even an
immortal being without them being able
to regenerate also the ability to steal
Souls as well as the ability to
transform into the unbelievably strong
endora beast of destruction after
sacrificing six of their hearts to do it
there's also the ability to regenerate
and so on in the past humans like the
new generation holy nights have consumed
the blood of demons in order to increase
their own power however not all humans
can handle ingesting demon blood and
those who are unable to handle it end up
exploding and finally we have the
goddess clan the final major race in the
world of the seven deadly sins is the
goddess clan as ancient rivals of the
demons they fought together with the
other races against the demon clan
during the holy war although the goddess
clan was on the winning side of the holy
war they suffered tremendous losses and
in order to seal away the demon clan
members of the goddess clan had to
sacrifice their ability to maintain a
physical form in the present time they
can possess anatomy objects such as a
sword and they can use the body of
another living being as a vessel but
they cannot take a physical form of
their own the goddess clan is mostly
made up of female beings but like the
demon clan and their ten commandments
the goddesses also have their own
special elite force known as the four
Archangels the four Archangels are
powerful angelic figures who unlike the
other members of the goddess clan appear
to be male members of the goddess clan
can be distinguished by their large
angel
wings and their appearance was clearly
inspired by the angels of the Bible
members of the goddess clan are known
for a number of unique abilities
including the power to heal the ability
to fly and the ability to purge and
destroy Dark Souls such as the souls of
demons in general the goddess clan
possesses a variety of abilities that
are especially effective in fighting
against demons and now let's move on to
the minor races the groups that are
either subcategories of one of the
larger races or clans or groups that
don't fit into any of the other
categories mentioned but are relatively
few in numbers so they are not
considered a major force in the world of
the seven deadly sins first up we have
the beast men not those guys this guy
beast men are creatures who have a
humanoid body but the head of an animal
and they may also have claws fur and
other animalistic features to put it
simply they are a mixture of beasts and
men hence the name beast men the only
beast man that we really got to know in
any significant way in the story so far
is Shivaji a fox man or where Fox who
essentially raised bond when bond was
young jeeva go was shown to be capable
of transforming into a human on command
even though that is not his true form so
we can speculate that perhaps like the
fairies all Beast men have the ability
to change their appearance in order to
look like humans the beast men have
strong animalistic abilities and
instincts which makes sense since they
are part beasts however they appear to
have been driven to the brink of
extinction by humans historically humans
have feared the beast men and seen them
as monsters kind of like the stories of
evil werewolves in our own world
aside from Chicago who is a fox man or
where Fox the other beast men have been
mentioned in the story include juegos
son also aware Fox and a Wolf Man or
werewolf that meliodas and Liz were sent
to hunt down once in the past then we
have the vampires yes the world of the
seven deadly sins also has vampires the
vampire
were allied with the demon clan during
the holy war and because of this some
believe that vampires are just another
type of demon but the vampires are
actually a separate minor race in the
world of the seven deadly sins and they
are not technically part of the demon
clan vampires look a lot like humans but
they also have sharp fangs and they are
able to turn humans into vampires by
biting them the humans that they turn
will then be compelled to serve them the
vampires feed on human blood but as a
race they are stronger than humans and
have a much longer lifespan next up are
the druids
the druids are human but they are a
unique group of humans that live in
isolation from other humans deep inside
the forest
the Druids look like normal humans
although many of them tend to have
silver hair or white hair
the Druids worship the goddess clan and
they considered a demon clan to be their
natural enemy
unlike most ordinary humans the Druids
are much more in touch with nature with
animals and with the spirit world and
they are able to perform magical spells
and techniques that normal humans cannot
these spells include the ability to heal
as well as the power to destroy dark and
corrupt souls such as the souls of
demons which are all techniques that
they share with the goddess clan it is
believed that these techniques were
taught to the druids
by the goddess clan as a reward for
their devotion to the goddesses and
finally we have the category that I will
refer to as other because it includes
hybrid artificial and unknown races some
characters from the seven deadly sins do
not really fit into any of the
categories that we talked about so far
these characters include gold third the
goat sin of lust who is an artificially
created doll and bond who used to be
human but became immortal after drinking
from the Fountain of Youth
now most of you probably know who this
next character is but just in case you
don't I won't name
but the fact is that in the seven deadly
sins there is also a character who is
the reincarnation of a goddess but is
currently in the body of a human druid
because of this this characters magical
powers are much greater than the powers
of a regular druid finally the race of
merlin de Bourgh sin of gluttony is
still unknown what we do know about
Merlin is that Merlin is not her true
name but just an alias that she uses
because her true name cannot be
pronounced by humans she was born in
beli a Lowen a city once known as the
capital of the Wizards and her birth
immediately attracted attention because
she was born with an amazing magical
power known as infinity the city of
Valhalla Wayne and the Wizards that
lived there were neutral during the holy
war but due to her unprecedented power
the warring goddess and demon clans both
tried to get Merlin to come over to
their side and they each offered secret
magical knowledge in return for her
support rather than picking either side
Merlin took the knowledge offered by
both sides angry that they've been
tricked the rulers of the goddess and
demon clans destroyed the entire city of
beli eluate but Merlin managed to escape
the destruction and she became the only
known survivor from the capital of the
Wizards now the question is is Merlin a
member of some separate wizard race a
race that was neutral during the
conflict and that is why her name cannot
be pronounced by humans because she is
not human but a member of this wizard
race perhaps after the destruction of
beli Alwyn this wizard race was
virtually destroyed along with the city
and that explains why we don't know more
about them they are essentially a lost
and forgotten race that's one option
but perhaps Merlin is just a really
special human or druid that was born
with an incredible power kind of like
esken or or maybe Merlin is somehow a
mix of different powerful races or
something else entirely we can't be sure
at this point
but that's what makes the world of the
seven deadly sins so unique there are so
many different and interesting races and
clans and yet there are still a ton of
mysteries and unknowns surrounding all
of them let me know down in the comments
what you think Merlin's true race is and
also don't forget to let me know which
race or clan you would want to be a part
of if you have the choice if you enjoy
the seven deadly sins content on this
channel be sure to leave a like to let
me know and if you are new don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell make sure you vote in the Twitter
poll for what type of seven deadly sins
content you want to see on this channel
in the future you can follow us on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar as
always thank you all so much for
watching your support really does mean a
lot and until next time see us space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]